cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump into the first
story from the New York Times right wing
Rebels block defense bill again rebuking
McCarthy on spending it was the second
time in a week that hard right
Republicans I love that I don't I don't
know what that means had defied speaker
Kevin McCarthy on a spending measure
signaling that the GOP was still far
from agreement on a bill to fund the
government all right let's just start
from the beginning we got Matt Gates
here Matt what's happening
so the government runs out of money at
the end of September and we've known
that for a year and that is the money
that was agreed to with Mitch McConnell
and Nancy Pelosi as part of the massive
Omnibus that most conservatives and I
think most regular folks opposed and uh
we made a commitment in January as part
of the speaker contest that we would not
govern by having one up or down vote on
every disparate agency of government
through continuing resolutions or
Omnibus bills you never get the type of
specific review of anything when you do
that so McCarthy agreed to that here we
are at the end of the month and we've
only passed one of the 12 like single
subject spending bills and that's got a
lot of people concerns McCarthy
initially said well what we really need
to do is pass a continuing resolution
again which you know this country has
been governed by continuing resolution
or Omnibus since the mid 90s
I know Omnibus is when you pack a bunch
of things into one bill and then get
someone but what's a continuing
resolution A continuing resolution is
however things are being funded right
now just fund them the same way next
year with increases for you know
inflation cost of living
so so just keep doing the everything the
way it's always been done is the
definition of a continuing resolution I
do not believe that is a serious and
responsible way to govern and I believe
the reason we have a 32 trillion dollar
debt is because we have governed this
way since the mid 90s so McCarthy wanted
to do that and say well that'll just buy
us time and we'll just do a continuing
resolution for a little bit but don't
worry after that we'll really get our
single subject spending bills in order
I've heard the same for seven
years I've been here and it's always the
same Rhythm and so I got a group of
conservatives together and we said we
will never vote up or down for every
agency of government together ever again
we have to impose discipline on this
process where there is programmatic
analysis and review and a determination
as to what's working and what's not
working and the ability to actually
isolate some of the most weaponized
programs and excise them from the
government budget strategy this is not
just a right-wing idea to your point
like when we were in the speaker contest
fighting for this
no less than AOC went on Rachel Maddow
and said what the Republic what the
freedom caucus what the conservatives
are fighting for here would actually be
good for everyone on The Young Turks
people who loathe me and said they
loathed me said Well if you really think
about it these single subject bills
could help us really evaluate our
priorities as a nation
they even the New York Times ran an
opinion piece Matt Gates is right about
McCarthy breaking those commitments so
in Washington people don't think you
have to live up to your promises they
think you could just kind of
your way through oh you make a promise
it's a few months later you ignore it
you engage in some other power trading
Enterprise we got together and said no
you have to keep your word we're not
voting for these and then today
we add a little bit of a breakthrough
I just left a closed door meeting with
some of the most moderate members from
New York some of the most conservative
members from around the country and they
acknowledged that the votes do not exist
to pass a continuing resolution and they
sat down and said what are the first
four single subject spending bills you'd
like us to consider oh wow and we said
well you know if we're going into a
shutdown let's fund the dod and again
our Appropriations bill has all the
gating to keep money away from the
gender reassignment surgeries and the
dod becoming an abortion travel agency
and all the stuff that that has been
really problematic about the dod second
the Border our Department of Homeland
Security funding bill that that pays the
TSA agents that pays Customs and Border
Patrol that pays ice third uh we want
deep cuts to the Department of State and
foreign Ops we think like an easy place
to show good faith on deep Cuts is
foreign aid because if we're out of
money maybe we should give we should
borrow less of it to give it to other
countries
um and and then the final one is the
agriculture Appropriations bill that
that we agreed to to bring up and debate
because there's so much waste in the
food stamps program there's so much
opportunity for savings with work basic
work requirements and we think we can
have deep Cuts there so if you get all
that together put it up get it moving in
single subject review I think you can
build real momentum so the house uh has
a really abandoned the McCarthy CR
strategy today and has embraced the math
gate strategy of single subject spending
bills and that's not to my credit that's
to the credit of some of the moderates
who I think wised up and said well
if we're going to go into a shutdown
let's at least lay out what our
priorities are and by the way it is
divided government so on those single
subject bills we're going to have to
negotiate with Democrats and and I think
you know that is the situation the
voters have put us in but at least we
can cast a vision by passing our bills
and then having I think uh the best
posture to negotiate with the Senate and
the white house so I feel I feel more
productive today than I did yesterday
when my sole goal was to kill governing
by continuing resolution I think we've
got that pretty well buried six feet
under for now there there's a threat
from moderate Republicans uh to the gate
strategy and it sort of goes like this
well if if we you know here we are at
the End of the Road Gates wants to spit
out all these single subject bills and
we just don't think there's time now
whose fault is that that's the Speaker
of The house's fault that's the
Appropriations chair's Fault by the way
when we were negotiating this bill last
night trying to get together the
Appropriations chair left to go to a
fundraiser
for with lobbyists who is the
Appropriations chair her name is Kay
Granger and she left the meeting where
we were going over funding the
government because she didn't want to
miss uh scooping up checks from
lobbyists is this the first uh time
there's been not there's not been an
Omnibus or a CR in what decades or yeah
I mean this is the first time since I
think 1997. you can check me on that but
but but but to get that here's what we
have to avoid so one of the one of the
bizarre rules of the house is if you
ever have 218 signatures on any piece of
legislation it's do not pass go do not
collect 200 that legislation goes
directly to the floor so all 213
Democrats are willing to sign what's
called a clean continuing resolution
which is no changes to the government
keep funding the woke weaponized
government why wouldn't they this was
the deal that McConnell and Pelosi
initially made they'd continue that
forever under under those terms so
they've got a clean CR and what the
threat is is that five uh you know
liberal or moderate Republicans could
just say we don't want to do the single
subject bills we don't want to go
through the pain of doing the cuts to
foreign aid or the food stamps or
anything like that so we're just gonna
go sign what's called a discharge
petition and then just move that thing
like through it they they
absolutely could and you know to those
Republicans who would want to take that
route I think that's wonderful and Liz
Cheney and Adam kinzinger will will be
there waiting at the bar afterwards when
you retire and never get reelected every
Republican who would sign a discharge
petition with the Democrats will be
signing their own political death
warrant and handing it to their
executioner because it'll be the
Democrats hunting them and taking them
out of office and every one of them will
lose their re-election some would lose
it in a primary someone lose it in a
general but the good news is actually
some of the folks that might otherwise
do that I think have really bought into
my strategy to move single subject
individual spending but it's not even
about a strategy it's about what is
right for this country that we've long
complained all I as far as as long as
I've been uh active in or as long as
I've been an adult dealing with politics
the idea that what do they bring in like
a wagon with all the paper 5000 Pages
they wheeled it into Congress or
whatever like okay you're voting on this
you can't read it sign it that's insane
and what if you want to vote for the
veterans programs and against the
Department of Education like what if you
want to vote for the military but
against foreign aid they never give you
that opportunity so they just come to
you put it all in front of you and say
well they threaten you with shutdown
politics and then say what are you
you're not a member of the team you want
to hurt the economy or you want to hurt
the country and in the end it's all just
a march to Perdition because because we
we are 32 trillion in debt running up
against two trillion annual deficits at
a time when the global economy is
de-dollarizing yeah this is they call it
a defense bill that is being just that
you were pushing back against is that
it's a defense spending Bill like what
is it what else does that entail like
how how long does it take to debate a
single issue if you've taken these
singles the defense bill has 186
amendments that's what it's not a
defense bill they call it the defense
you look bad for going against it
no well this particular bill is just is
a single subject defense Appropriations
bill but you know there's Amendment
sought to take out the Ukraine money
there's there's amendments where people
want different things to happen with
military policy or with uh mission that
relates to their District or their
constituents and by the way that's what
governing looks like mowing through
those amendments giving them their 10
minutes of debate each debating all
night if we have to all morning and then
let the votes fall where they may I'm
okay with that what I'm not okay with is
a few people in a back room come up with
that 5 000 page Bill and you've got you
know a day or two to figure out whether
or not you're pro-government or
anti-government how lazy and nihilistic
that is so these people these people
don't want to do work that's what I'm
wondering is it just doesn't work so you
mentioned one woman goes off to a dinner
with lobbyists or whatever
yeah she could she couldn't be bothered
to work with us on what should be the
non-defense discretionary number that we
have and how should we consider what
amendments should be voted on or not
voted on she left to go to a lobbyist
fundraiser well so let me ask you what
does this mean what does a government
shutdown mean for the for the average
person I tell you what it means in my
district and the Florida Panhandle means
tens of thousands of people go without a
paycheck who keep our country safe who
are the civil servants doing the highest
end research it means that you know the
weapons that we're testing to ensure
that America holds The High Ground that
that goes on hold it means that that you
know in in an era where 61 of of people
in this country are living paycheck to
paycheck that that people will be you
know deeply uncomfortable if this thing
lasts you know more than a month it
shouldn't it shouldn't have to
um I think that we are destined for a a
short shutdown if we can get the and
that's because our speaker was not doing
the work in the spring and in the summer
you know presenting these bills on the
floor for us to work through them over
time but I think that's not a a bug of
the system I think it's a feature I
think the whole goal is to set these
deadlines where we don't do any work and
then at the end you centralize power
with the donor class and the lobbyists
because if they give a lot of money they
don't really they the reason they give
that money is to not have individual
review of their programs it's just to
get the people they give the money to to
make sure that their special interest is
covered by the legislation and if the
donors are going to say the speaker of
the house it's a lot easier to
centralize your lobbying on a single
individual than it is the entirety of
Congress and you heard all my colleagues
during the speaker contest debase
themselves going to the floor saying
Kevin McCarthy has owed the speakership
because of how much money he's raised
and given us that was why that was the
game that was the price many of my
colleagues used that as the centerpiece
of their argument as to why we ought to
vote for him I used it as a centerpiece
of why we shouldn't vote for him because
maybe we shouldn't vote some for someone
who's sold shares of themselves
my idea is that my hope is that the
ideas you have and the way you do things
I hope it's winning
well it's I tell you what we got the
wind at our back and and
we didn't have the buy-in that we have
today from Republican moderates to go
through these bills individually I think
they're coming to realize that is the
only way we're going to get through this
but and I know this is wonky but you
have a very sophisticated audience and I
got some thoughts to share I've been out
in America and I know a little bit about
the typical audience but but you know
the the the the circumstances if we do
single subject spending bills and at the
same time have a continuing resolution
that we pass well then I know what the
Senate will do those that swampy
institution will just pick up the
continuing resolution negotiate its
terms and forget about all of the
individual review of programs and and
that is that is unserious that is
unpatriotic
for people who get the opportunity to be
on the board of directors the most
powerful country I I think
I don't know if it's the internet or
whatever the younger generation is more
tuned in to a certain degree
the idea that they would cart in 5000
pages and say we know you're not going
to read it and you can't sign it or else
that's that or else your campaign money
goes away right or else your committee
assignments yeah could be jeopardized
otherwise your leadership your gavel if
you're a chair or a ranking member on a
committee you could lose that and it got
you got to break it and then that's why
people go home and say you know what I
know that that we're all bankrupt we're
killing the dollar we're destroying the
American dream but I had to vote to keep
everything open because you know our
troops and our veterans would you
imagine how long the Constitution would
be if it was drafted today oh would you
imagine how many lawyers would have been
involved with writing it amount of money
being spent on it lobbying for it Jesus
yeah you had an interesting question uh
before the show that I wanted to wait on
and you said uh a question about default
do you wanna yeah so look there's a lot
of
um Nuance to any kind of shutdown and
all no shutdown is the same right it all
changes and look my my I have a number
of issues but one of my major issues
when it comes to default is the faith
and credit of the U.S right like we're
the dollar is already under assault
we're having massive issues because of
our economic issues because of inflation
the dog's been an assault for a long
time certainly on this Administration my
worry my great worry is a default that's
something I cannot sit with
we'll see so what's yeah you you asked
earlier I don't want to tell you how do
I mean how long will it take like how
many days it take before we say okay now
we're at the point where we can we have
to start paying our interest rates on
our bonds yeah default of course is
different than the government running
out of money right those the two things
don't align we're we're at no risk of
default because we have abolished the
debt limit we we through the bad debt
deal that McCarthy valade for Democrats
into law through that there is there is
no limit to the amount of fed policy
that can exist to keep printing money
the problem is that money can't go to
deploy to government agencies to run
government programs that are deemed
non-essential during a shutdown but you
can increase the debt if the government
shutdown technically well no there is no
there is no limit to the amount of
dollars we will pay on interest until
January of 2025. that is that is the
feature of the this this is the in
absolutely the May the May deal that the
macaron no well that's it that's that's
a different
um that's a different feature that's if
the 12 spending bills are not passed by
March
then we do uh fund everything exactly
the same except take a one percent
haircut starting in March and and
McCarthy and the advocates for the the
fiscal responsibility act which was
fiscally irresponsible they would say
but that's a cut in spending we should
celebrate that now government spending
grew by 40 during covet
and a lot of that was through
entitlement programs because eligibility
ballooned but you can't grow government
by 40 and then say that the the
grandiose win we got was a one percent
haircut starting March of 2024. also we
but we I'm sorry oh opportunity cost if
you stop spending one percent on
something that could be making you a two
percent return you're actually losing
money so like just stopping certain
expenditures is not necessarily a good
profit but see that's that's a big
debate we were having today because we
had I had one member look at me and say
well Matt here's here's really where I
can get on board with you if you just
say across the board everyone takes you
know a seven eight percent haircut
everyone gets it this every program gets
it the same I think that's great what I
don't want to do is have to go in and
make value judgments about vertical Cuts
who gets vertical cuts and who doesn't
because I'm really worried that if we
did that there's some Transportation
projects in my district that would be
deemed a boondoggle or wasteful and and
might be cut so it can't be a
merit-based analysis it has to be a
uniform uh reduction wait wait what
because it's not private sector yeah
he's basically saying there's a strong
possibility they're going to find out
that we're wasting money please don't
take our money away well and so long as
everyone's wasteful spending is reduced
by an equal amount and we don't we don't
we don't look at logic or Reason where
my district might do worse thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time